very few of us know how we were
conceived yeah I try to find out for my
mother yeah what but that's such a big
deal
he didn't watch Ronnie Lee yeah you saw
your mom and dad caught my mom and dad
in a threesome I wasn't home right I
can't were supposed to be out I was out
yeah and I came in on it what was the
pinyon I don't even think they know I
came in the [ __ ] house it was closed
did you beat off two while they were
doing it it's possibility I didn't do it
while I was watching he was listening I
went back in my [ __ ] room a drunk dog
went back in my room and sporty the dog
Ronnie if I heard my parents and through
the door having a threesome the last
thing they would do is go to my room and
jerk off I would probably vomit I mean
dude it's so you're so sexed up that
your parents having sex got you charged
up and you went in jerk don't think
about that I'm thinking about that's
weird like you didn't try to see what I
did I admitted to it what are you
talking about dude his balls around her
with you you said you could see their
feet and stuff yeah
my parents I remember being a ninth
grade my parents came home did you jerk
off it's to this day it traumatizes me
remembering it I remember like he is so
[ __ ] freaked out by it but I did not
get a hard-on that's a weird move for
parents to to have sex so loud that your
kids can hear in the next they were
drunk from a wedding in Ronnie's case he
came home and they were having a
threesome yeah I was I see and then he
heard one upstairs what is it they
didn't hear me come my way I was like
running to another I want to know what
he pictured when he was up there in his
bathroom yeah I would run into the other
room and like hide he got down on the
floor to see and he saw their feed and
then he goes to his room but what did
you do like you had a boner while you
were listening to them or you had the
boner when you got in the room when you
got in your bedroom I already had
already had a bone I mean listening to
their voices having sex you were hearing
your mom and dad and you got a bomb I
heard people that's what I heard I would
like you know Boyd was did you in your
parents house yeah I heard I wasn't
listening but Ron my father Ron can you
imagine [ __ ] but Ron could you excuse
me Gary I did you they were but I wasn't
thinking about it like that
run can you imagine thinking about it
like a [ __ ] porno movie okay Ron can
you run can you imagine a world [ __ ]
look at me you didn't think of them as
people as just people like in a [ __ ]
movie but they're your parents I didn't
think of them that way when I went and
jerked off I put a guard up Ronnie can
you imagine a world where people jerk
off to their parents having sex think
about that doesn't that sound strange to
you when you really analyze yeah the
whole world what what do you mean what
do you think why would that
everything which six is know is like not
good for you wait a second run when I
got to my [ __ ] bed and it was jerking
off I'm thinking about it and what were
you thinking about as it was like a
[ __ ] porno movie but were you
picturing you and your mom
three people that's it well how come you
don't stop moans like my mom you don't
like to hear your mother being sexual
and your father being sexual it's so
whacked out and it's like so hard whack
down because it's hard to fix the
[ __ ] life we know it's a fact of life
but to hear it and to experience it my
first thought wouldn't be to have a
boner in jerk off okay
well that's you saying you're an unusual
guy I mean yeah I'm weird I'm [ __ ] I
think that's weird maybe it maybe it is
I don't know I'm syan find it weird I
find that weirder the fact that he
doesn't find it weird is there anybody
here who thinks Ronnie isn't weird for
jerking off to his parents there's only
one way to get to the bottom of this
yeah we need to hypnotize Ronnie yeah oh
my god yeah that'd be good do what you
gotta do like a merge got it oh look
there's my dad's taint I'm getting odd
did you finish before them and then how
to lately
let me time it right well squirt it's
almost like Ronnie's origin story like
man or Batman like how did Batman become
Batman like Ronnie so psyched up now
like he's on fire but like his origin
story is it came from like coming with
his parents when they were having a
threesome and I come from I just you
know a creep was born you know what I
mean that's kind of cool I'm a creep